you know preparing for an earthquake is
multi-faceted multi-dimensional and the
first thing really is being aware yes
I've said that earthquakes can occur
anywhere but they're more likely some
places than others so you know basic
awareness of where your house where you
work where you are relative to the
faults that might cause an earthquake
that's a matter of public education but
once you know what your risk might be
you have to make some sort of personal
judgment or if you're a government some
sort of social judgement about the level
of risk that you're willing to accept it
is going to be and if you're willing to
accept or only willing to accept a low
level of risk then there are a number of
things you need to do you need to ensure
that major infrastructure is resilient
that our water lines our power lines are
built in such a way so that they won't
break that bridges and highways won't
fall down that fire stations will remain
standing so that the fire personnel can
respond and that hospitals remain
standing with respect to individuals in
their homes if you're an earthquake zone
ensuring that your building is up to
code if a code exists ensuring that you
follow that code and even little things
like keeping the knickknacks away from
the edge of the shelf
keeping your dishes way back those are
the sorts of things that can make the
difference between sort of ho-hum boy
was at an interesting event to something
that was a disaster and these are all
written down you can go to the FEMA
websites USGS websites they're a whole
list of these things the problem arises
when first you don't have building codes
or those codes aren't enforced that was
a situation in Haiti where you don't
have the national or social wealth to
actually consider this something you can
do I mean they're the and I don't mean
to bring up Haiti constantly but the
issue there was that there were so many
sort of day-to-day problems facing Haiti
culture and Haiti government
that's something that might happen
really can't get on the radar screen and
you could argue the right or wrong to
that but that basically is a situation
and sad to say that's tapped us
throughout the world so you know that
the basic things are really quite easy
to do if you've got the money to do them
and if you've got the public awareness
to do them and if you've got the
political will to do them if you're
dealing with the Commons if you're
dealing with infrastructure where you
don't have the political will or the
wealth there are a number of things that
the community is trying to do there's a
lot of concentration on building
small-scale community awareness so that
the awareness of disaster the awareness
of potential disaster I should say
occurs almost at the household level and
enabling people to make decisions but
also giving them sort of the simple
things that they that they could do on a
day to day basis not just for
earthquakes but for floods for
landslides and for that matter for
longer-term issues like sea level rise
and climate change you know one of the
one of the key things that we're doing
at our Institute and and elsewhere is
trying to to bring the knowledge we have
about Earth processes it's a dynamic
planet it's fun to look at we enjoy
doing that but it affects people and one
of the things we're trying to do is to
bring that knowledge not just throw it
over the fence so that policymakers can
use it because you know there's not a
feedback in that kind of a system we
really scientists need to understand
social and cultural constraints on using
the information and in fact even the
utility of the information that they
provide and if I may say I think the
social scientists and governments and
NGOs need to know what they don't know
and that's a difficult task but to be
honest it's an interesting and important
thing to do and we're getting better at
it